hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner games Thursday
again we got another dead stream recap
it really wasn't much today we are in
the middle of an event and most of the
big news was released at the release of
the event so I didn't really expect too
much to happen afterwards and we
probably won't be getting much next week
but we still have a few things one thing
I forgot to cover last week and then
another thing you make sure to like to
be if you do enjoy subscribe if you're
new because I covered the news content
of for honor and with that let's get
started so first up April 5th will be
the documentary of for honor it was
supposed to release yesterday but it got
postponed to April 5th if you don't know
Ubisoft has made an independent
documentary about the game for honor
talking about the process of enzyme
behind the scenes work and a whole lot
of other stuff that they haven't told us
yet so if you're interested it should be
live April 5th on Netflix I'm gonna be
watching this once it releases and maybe
give my thoughts in it in a future video
so if I do definitely look out for that
and if you have access to Netflix go
check out the documentary in terms of
some other news be the faction with the
most amount of takedowns is the new
event order today tomorrow is going to
be starting a loot fess of a pairing
that with the strategy of what I've made
to get the most gear as quick as
possible you'll get all the loot that
you could possibly use in no time at all
that video will be in the top right
right now or at the end of this video if
you want to see that I definitely highly
recommend checking that out and then
lastly we have some patch notes from
last week that I forgot to cover so this
is this patch that I'm already reading
to you right now and about a second is
already live as of the new event so
don't worry this isn't coming in the
future it's already present
we have warlord JJ and black prior
involved in this little recent patch
warlord got a buff to his head but it's
Oh his head but into stab damage was
originally 12 damage but it's now 15 so
that got raised a bit Jing Jun's top
heavy finisher his side heavy finisher
light attack finisher and zone attacks
have all been decreased from damage
so JJ's top heavy finisher was 45 it's
now 38 his side heavy finisher was 40
does 35 his light attack finisher was 20
and out does 18 and the zone attacks
were 28 and they now do 25 because a lot
of people had a problem with JJ being
super powerful and he could do immense
amounts of damage and a small amount of
time so they did decrease the dam
there's just a little bit to see how
that goes with him for now and then for
black prior he also got a nerf he they
decreased the amount of damage from his
light and heavy finishers this was
usually because people would do the
light attack shield bash the light
attack or a light attack shield bash
follow up heavy type of combo and it
would just be too much because as soon
as the bash hits you that follow-up
light attack is guaranteed the heavy is
not but you can also dodge the show the
shield bash as well but if you happen to
not dodge it that light attack is
guaranteed and you're gonna be losing a
lot of your health so the light attacks
are now down from 20 they're not going
to be 17 and the heavy attacks are now
35 instead of 40 and but do remember
these are the finishers meaning these
are the last lights and the combo not
the ones that start it on top of that
they also increased the Blackfriars
recovery for the jawbreakers now I'm
gonna be honest I actually don't know
what jawbreakers is I'm pretty sure it's
a move that he has I would assume but
I've never seen it in the movies unless
I carelessly didn't read through it so
if any of you guys know what the
jawbreakers move is or whatever it
happens to be definite let me know in
the comments because I don't remember
seeing this on the move set and then on
top of that the increased black Pryor's
full block stance exit animation to 400
milliseconds it was originally 200
milliseconds meaning this is a huge nerf
all around his light attacks are gonna
be doing less on the finishers the heavy
finishers are gonna be doing less it
takes longer to recover from the
jawbreakers move and exiting full block
is 200 milliseconds longer than it used
to be he's eliminated thoughts on the
patch notes in the comments would love
to know your thoughts that guy is gonna
be end of the video if you guys did
enjoy this be sure to let me know by
liking the video commenting your
favorite part about it and then
subscribing for more for honor news
content my two most recent videos are
gonna be popping up if you guys want to
check that out with that have a girl
yesterday peace out and enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]